woke lightyear film with lesbian kiss
flops at the box office you might ask
yourself why does a lesbian kiss need to
be in a cartoon for kids
why well because there's an empty space
and a woke cause needs to fill it that's
why
there's an empty space and a woke cause
needs to fill it
every time
every time
okay well they suffered because they
didn't do so well at the box office
let's take a look light-year disney film
giving toy story fans the chance to
experience the backstory of buzz
lightyear i didn't see toy story so
failed to take off after a series of
controversies surrounding a lesbian kiss
scene despite disney positioning the
film for success by debuting light year
as their first theater-only movie in
over a year the film flopped can't
imagine why at the box office bringing
in nearly 20 million dollars less than
the projected 70 million for opening
weekend well
maybe parents decided
sat back and said i just want to take my
kids to see a cartoon
i i wasn't signing up for like
woke lessons on you know pronouns and
and and what it means to be a lesbian
and what maybe they didn't maybe they
didn't want to do that with their
saturday
i can't imagine why why does this stuff
need to be in everything
the franchise also acts tim allen who
was the original voice of buzz lightyear
back in the toy story days actress
patricia heaton who co-starred with
allen in the sitcom home improvement
blasted pixar saying that allen was the
one element that made moviegoers want to
see the film
skip down a little speculation royale
that he was pulled from the project for
having been a supporter of president
donald trump
wouldn't that be just fitting wouldn't
surprise me
i can't say it was true or wasn't it
wouldn't surprise me though
this disney stuff is oh and this is this
is great i have to read more wait i
underlined this for a reason the film
had caught a lesbian kiss scene but
after disney faced backlash for not
opposing ron desantis bill to keep talks
of sexuality out of elementary
classrooms infamously dubbed the don't
say gay bill
disney employees use the ax scene as
fuel for accusations that the company
wasn't doing enough to be an ally to the
lgbtq plus community so in other words
they were like we need to take a stand
we need to be the anti-desantis even
though there is no don't say gay bill
again don't take the bait you're smarter
than that go look for the words don't
say gay in the bill
they're not there there is no don't say
gay bill
there is no don't say gay bill remember
that
but they needed to say well we need to
be the antithesis to ronda santos he's
being painted as anti-gay we're not
doing enough we got to put the lesbian
kiss scene back in
imagine activism in the cartoon industry
is what you have now activism and
they're not shy about it
let's skip to the second page remember
this stuff
the box office bus doesn't come as a
total surprise however around the same
time as the same-sex kiss was restored
in march disney's corporate president
carrie burke said in a company meeting
that she wants quote many many many
lgbtqia characters in our stories
and that she wanted at least 50 of the
characters to be lgbtq plus at the same
meeting disney's executive producer
spoke about her quote not at all secret
gay agenda
so they're telling you
it's not secret
they're not quite they're telling you
they're telling you we are an agenda
driven company
you're not going to be watching snow
white cinderella and pinocchio the way
you once did
we're here to change minds about these
issues and we're going to get to your
kids first
so you wake up on a saturday you know
maybe you don't do the research on the
cartoon maybe you think about oh when i
was young i went and saw disney cartoons
this looks like a good one maybe that
scene's not in the promo you show up at
the movie theater you sit there and now
you have to be uncomfortable around your
kids asking questions they're
uncomfortable why because kids don't
want to see that they don't want to see
any of it kids don't want to see kissing
at all
they don't want to see kissing at all
you know when they're like ew they're
kids they just want to watch a cartoon
they weren't looking for a lecture on
how to be woke that saturday afternoon
so they sink at the box office and what
i always say to parents is use your
dollars you see what's going on listen i
love disney world i do i went there when
i hosted the view we we did a week at
disney world i went on all the rides i
love rides i do think it has a certain
magical component you see cinderella's
castle i grew up watching those cartoons
i get it
but you have to realize what you're
promoting what your dollar goes to and
what is being used as activism now
activism for messages that you maybe you
maybe you don't even oppose the message
but you want to be the one to have it
with your kids
right
maybe you're on board with what they're
saying but you're like hmm i don't
really want a company to have a gay
agenda i want to have those
conversations at home with my own child
i don't need him or her to learn it
through a cartoon on a saturday
afternoon maybe you're in that camp
regardless
just know what you give your dollars to
they take it and they grow
that agenda
so make a decision and i always say
tyler i always say your dollar counts
parents have purchasing power this is
the free market right when the film
tanks
they get a little memo that's not to say
they'll change
because i think the agenda is bigger
than whether or not this particular
movie succeeds i think they're like well
let's reach who we can and it's more
important for us to be viewed as woke
than for the film to do well
i was just i was looking at this next
line i mean this is astounding in april
i and i looked at this article it's a
trafalgar poll polling revealed that 68
of americans are quote less likely to do
business with disney after the company's
sexual politics were revealed 70 of
people they're sick of it you know and
this is like uh remember when john cena
uh was talking about the fast and
furious and he referenced hong kong
and he got a whole bunch of [ __ ] so he
came out and apologized in chinese
yes
yes in chinese nonetheless i do it's
it's people are getting sick of this
stuff and we'll i mean we'll see what
happens you know yesterday i was getting
a haircut and i was talking to the guy
at the bar looks very nice by the way
thank you
um and i was talking with the barber and
and you know it's he's representative of
so many people like we do this for
living like i do this with pat i do this
you know i opine on things and this guy
was just cutting here and he's you could
tell he was like i'm sick of it all of
my money is going to bills rent
gas electric food and he he said you
know it used to be that i had to cut
seven people a day and i'd be fine i'd
do seven haircuts a day i'd be just fine
now i'm doing 14. i'm doing 14 haircuts
a day just to survive yeah
gas prices yeah can't buy a set of
headphones can't buy a new pair of
sneakers can't go to disney world i
can't do anything
he said this is he may not want to go to
disney world after what's going on now
but it's true you make a good point i
think it's not just we're talking about
cartoons today we're talking about kids
but this happened in sports too people
are so tired they're like can't i just
go to a football game can i just go this
is people this is your break usually
right we talked about a wind down
yesterday your break is like let me turn
on some sports let me just let's go to a
nice movie with the kids something
family friendly that's your break from
you know
aspects of life that are hard
life is not easy paying bills is not
easy gas prices you go to fill up your
gas tank and you're like i gotta do an
extra four haircuts this is real life
stuff people live and pay to paycheck to
paycheck but you know what if they can
have a little bit of enjoyment watch a
game you can't even do that anymore
without this woke politics being
injected to every fabric of everything
it's not just cartoons it's not even
just sports it's everything you can't
turn on i used to like to watch award
shows because i used to look at the
fashion
i'm not really that into fashion but i'd
be like oh i was very joan rivers i was
like girlfriend that dress
somebody did you wrong i was that person
at home but it was enjoyable my mom and
i used to be like her hair you know it
was fun very italian very critical
a little judgmental but funny and fun
my grandma used to sit around and do
that stuff she was joan rivers by the
way my grandma let me tell you my 100
year old grandma from naples
she wouldn't be having any of this she'd
be like honey you're a female done
honey you're a male done we're not
having this conversation over wouldn't
have cared wouldn't have given a lick
about what you had to say about her
either when she walked away
those were some people with guts that
generation you know with guts maybe
maybe because the people around them who
fought in wars didn't watch a children's
video about gender pronouns instead of
getting ready for combat maybe let's
just think about that for a second
so people need to wake up and i tell
parents use your purchasing power you
know really make your voices heard
because
this stuff is getting creepy
it's getting real creepy again you can
feel however you want about these issues
but the fact that there's no space where
it's not somebody trying to hold up a
pin or a sign trying to say i'm in the
cool club and you need to be too and now
it's being targeted at kids every turn
school cartoons where do they go to just
have a normal
kid experience
where they're not constantly being
injected either by big pharma or by woke
politics with something
i ask if you like the short clip you can
catch another one here or you can catch
the full episode right here
[Music]